fine I'll do it myself
hey youtubers is Charlie Kevin Feige was
teasing phase four and just how
different it was gonna look from all the
other Marvel films that have come before
it so I'm gonna explain what he said and
then do some predictions some of it's
pretty self-explanatory some of its kind
of vague here we go he said I think you
look at the comics as a guide although
certain titles might get relaunched or
rebooted and when he says titles he's
talking about movies the narrative
exists on a never ending continuum which
means that if they reboot one of the
characters like they they recast one of
the actors then all the stories that
that previous actor told using that
character all the stuff that jeremy
renner did will still exist in the
continuum they won't be rewriting that
even though they'll be going forward
with a new hawkeye a good example of
that would be if Marvel brought Kate
Bishop into the Cinematic Universe Kate
Bishop is the person who takes the
Hawkeye title from the Clint Martin
Hawkeye so it's like another character
comes along takes the mantle in the
comics they both exist at the same time
though so you have like team Hawkeye you
have boy Hawkeye girl Hawkeye so if you
haven't ever read Hawkeye's comic book
in the last couple of years it's
actually been really good but you get
the idea like a more direct example
would be like Sam Wilson the Falcon
taking the mantle of Captain America in
the comics if they did something like
that in the movies where someone else
took the mantle of Captain America it
wouldn't erase all the Chris Evans
Captain America stuff this is actually
pretty standard for comic book readers
but if you haven't read a comic book it
can seem kind of weird in the movies
where it's like hey you know they
rebooted the character does that mean
that all this other stuff doesn't exist
like when x-men Days of Future past
changed the x-men universe timeline I
feel like a lot of people who hadn't
read comics before weren't really sure
how that was gonna change their universe
but most of you guys will get it one of
the most enduring characters though is
Iron Man and Robert Downey jr. has
committed to playing the character for
forever so no matter who gets replaced
in the Avengers they will always be the
same Iron Man which I kind of like
because in like ten years they can do
old man Stark he'll be the thing that
links all of the Avengers stories across
space and time this one character then
Kevin Feige continues by saying I think
there will be a finality of moments of
Phase three as well as new beginnings
that will mark a different a very
different a distinct different chapter
in what will someday be a complete first
saga made up of three phases so what
he's talking about is thinking of
Marvel's phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 as a
kind of trilogy so they'll be a
beginning a middle and an end to that in
that bookend moment will tip the hat to
what phase four and everything going
forward is going to be if you guess that
the Infinity Gauntlet will have
something to do with that moment then
you are probably correct like Thanos
will do something terrible to the
universe the Avengers will fix it in
infinity war part two and in fixing it
they will change the universe forever
that will introduce new villains new
challenges new characters officially as
it stands right now the first film in
phase four is supposed to be in humans
but supposedly that's going to be pushed
there are a couple other films we know
are going to be happening during phase
four already you have the Black Panther
sequels you have the Captain Marvel
sequels if they're going to be sequels
of that we haven't even seen that
character appear yet you have the third
guardians of the galaxy movie you have
the Doctor Strange sequels so you have
all these new characters as they're
introducing in Phase three they'll get
their sequel movies during phase four
and then they'll decide whether or not
they're going to introduce a new
character or they're going to reboot one
of the existing characters so from a
very practical standpoint just the
characters are gonna look very different
because they will literally be different
characters like the first three phases
are dominated by the classic Avengers
team you have Thor Captain America Iron
Man Hulk all those other characters
phase four will probably double down on
all the new ones that were just starting
to meet now so it'll be different in
that sense but also I think we're gonna
see a transition into more mystical
cosmic story elements like look at this
panel here Thanos versus Mephisto if
someone were to ask you if that was
going to be in one of the movies you
would laugh at them like hah they
haven't even gotten close to magic we're
not even gonna see Doctor Strange till
later this year and the big villain of
that does not look like mythos to-- so
if it's gonna take the weirdest most
mystical character years and years to
get to someone like Mephisto to get to
like a god then how long is it gonna
take for the big Avengers films to get
there
that's what I think phase four is gonna
get into they're gonna be a little
bolder with their story and their
character choices when it comes to
villains and supporting characters think
about what the original Iron Man movie
looked like and then think about what
guardians of the galaxy look like so
much weirder I think phase four is gonna
be a step up the weird scale just like
guardians of the galaxy was a big step
up the weird scale so one of my first
big predictions is
during phase four we will see a
supernatural villain on the level of
Mephisto now he's just one of the
biggest examples because he's a doctor
strange villain and they've already
announced the Doctor Strange movie there
are a lot of other characters they can
do you have a character like eternity
one of the great cosmic powers of the
Marvel Universe you have the idea of the
multiverse the Marvel movies haven't
even touched on that yet so I think
we'll see multiverse I think we'll see
more cosmic villains but they're gonna
push into that relatively carefully
they'll still be very personal stories
even though they'll get very weird
guardians of the galaxy is just a really
good example that something that went
really weird but was still a very
personal story we are Groot despite the
fact that there was a talking tree in a
talking raccoon my other big prediction
is that Captain Marvel is going to be
one of the leaders of the New Avengers
and phase 4 going forward now a lot of
that will depend on how successful that
franchise is because if the movie
doesn't do well enough then they won't
do sequels but I think Marvel has that a
track record that we can say even if
it's not the biggest movie that they
ever have
it'll still be really big like ant-man
was a risk for them and it did
wonderfully so that's why they moved up
ant-man and the wasp and the schedule
like originally they didn't have an
ant-man sequel during phase 3 and they
do now so I think it's gonna be the same
situation with Captain Marvel she'll
come along and she'll be so powerful but
unlike vision she will be fully human so
she'll be a little bit easier for
audiences to connect with so if she
doesn't outright replace Captain America
as leader of the Avengers I think she'll
be the strong number two because I feel
like what they could do with the Captain
America character to keep him around but
changed the way that he works changed
the dynamic that he has with the
characters is turn him into more of a
Nick Fury type character which is kind
of what the comics have done but the
movies might play with the way that
happens because it is gonna be a long
time before Chris Evans looks like old
Captain America without a lot of CG
here's my big question for you guys what
do you feel like they're gonna do with
some of these big Avengers characters in
phase four going forward not the new
characters but the old ones so they have
to find a way to put a new Avengers team
together while still using the classic
characters in some supporting way like I
feel like the easy pitch with Thor would
be to turn him into the Odin character
like Odin dies in the Marvel Universe
Thor takes his place so he can still be
in the movies but you have a good
explanation for why he isn't around all
that
and when he does show up he has the Thor
force so he also gets to become one of
the most powerful beings in the Marvel
Universe so what's gonna happen this
week is there's a whole bunch more
Captain America stuff happening the
flash is back and Game of Thrones is
premiering so be sure to subscribe to
get all those videos there's another
Suicide Squad Justice League video that
I'm working on a whole bunch a really
cool comic book stuff happening this
week while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
watch the Winter Soldier kick the
out of The Avengers and you can click
here to learn all about the spider-man
Home Coming movie thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you